ist impfen unsere einzige chance gegen
das corona virus auf der suche nach
einer antwort schauen wir auf die neuen
impfstoff typen tod und lebens
impfstoffe die m rna technologie und
ihre möglichkeiten und fragen nach den
alternativen zum impfen
ein kleiner pieks und wir sind vor
krankheiten ziemlich sicher geschützt
schon als babys und kleinkinder werden
wir so gegen viele gefährliche
infektionskrankheiten immunisiert es
gibt menschen die sind skeptisch
gegenüber den neuen impfstoffen gemeint
sind die vector und die em-arena
impfstoffen
diese liefern einen wichtigen ausschnitt
des genetischen codes eines erregers in
form eines bauplans an einige unserer
körperzellen dieser bauplan wird für den
impfstoff rein synthetisch im labor
hergestellt
schauen wir genauer auf die anderen
stoffe
sm steht dabei für messenger also
verboten der impfstoff übermittelt also
als bote erstmal nur einen bauplan
keinen teil eines erregers
[Musik]
bei den corona impfstoffen von beyond
reiser und moderner ist dass der bauplan
dass proteine
verpackt in eine fett hülle wird also
der bauplan des bike protein skizziert
einige zellen im körper bauen dann die
proteine des erregers nach dem
vorgegebenen plan und darauf reagiert
wiederum das immunsystem bildet
antikörper und programmiert so genannte
t zellen um diese proteine zu bekämpfen
der ganze vorgang gleicht einer
natürlichen infektion ohne dass der
körper mit dem gefährlichen erreger
konfrontiert wird im falle eines
angriffs durch das echte virus ist der
körper jetzt gut vorbereitet und kann
schnell reagiert die vector impfstoffe
von astrazeneca und johnson johnson
funktionieren ganz ähnlich nur dass der
bauplan das bike proteine als dna
bauplan in ein harmloses träger virus
eingebaut wird das sich allerdings nicht
mehr vermehren kann dieses verfahren ist
schon länger abrupt
vector und mr inhaltsstoffe wurden auch
als kreuz impfungen durchgeführt als ein
weg der impfstoff an einen anderen
impfstoff in dieser reihenfolge haben
die impfungen bisher zu einer guten
immunantwort geführt umgekehrt nur mit
dem vector impfstoff von johnson &
johnson für kinder unter zwölf jahren
müssen die m rna impfstoffe anders
dosiert werden die studien ergaben dass
es für die fünf bis elfjährigen nur etwa
ein drittel des impfstoffes von walter
kaiser braucht um eine ausreichende
immunantwort hervorzurufen
einige ungeimpfte warten derzeit noch
auf altbewährte impfstoff typen diese
werden umgangssprachlich oft als tot
oder lebend im stoffe bezeichnet dabei
geht es vor allem um zwei tut impfstoffe
gegen cupid 19
bei dem impfstoff von nowaks werden
künstlich hergestelltes bike proteine
des corona virus gespritzt sie können
die krankheit nicht auslösen aber das
immunsystem reagiert trotzdem und baut
einen schutz gegen den coup 19 erreger
auf der tod im stoff von val bever
arbeitet mit dem ganzen aber unschädlich
gemachten wäre
neben impfstoffe enthalten dagegen
kleinste mengen aktiver wären diese sind
jedoch in ihrer wirkung so stark
abgeschwächt dass die krankheit nicht
ausgelöst wird sie werden zum beispiel
gegen typische kinderkrankheiten wie
masern eingesetzt
hinter der im rna technologie steht dann
einfacher gedanke der körper soll in die
lage versetzt werden seine eigene
medizin herzustellen so funktioniert es
bei den kuwait 19 impfstoffen aber auch
als therapie gegen tumor wird wird die
emmeringer technologie eingesetzt
vereinfacht gesagt hier wird ein genauer
tumor plan erstellt und dann ein auf die
proteinen des tumors andere pasta
impfstoff entwickelt eine
individualisierte therapie für die
patienten
durch die pandemie hat die m rna
forschung einen enormen schub bekommen
auch finanziell
und andere wären rücken nun in den blick
die mithilfe dieser technologie
behandelt werden können so arbeitet bei
uns beispielsweise derzeit an mehreren
allem stoffen gegen grippe malaria
tuberkulose und hiv und auch an der
emmeringer therapie gegen verschiedene
krebsarten wird verstärkt geführt für
die kugel 19 impfstoffe mit m rna
spricht zum beispiel dass sie allgemein
recht gut verträglich sind es kommt zwar
häufig zu impfreaktion diese sind jedoch
ungefährlich und klingen schnell wieder
ab im rna impfstoffe können in kurzer
zeit in großen mengen hergestellt werden
auch auf veränderungen eines erregers
kann diese technologie sehr schnell
reagieren das ist wichtig denn viren
können in recht kurzer zeit ihre
genetischen informationen verändern also
mutieren dass koch 2 hat genau das getan
und die sogenannte delta variante hat
den ursprünglichen typ des virus
verträgt aber die mrm stoffe wirken auch
dagegen sehr effizient und bieten einen
hohen schutz aktuell bereitet die
omikron variante sorgen aber die
impfstoff firmen sind zuversichtlich
dass die dritte impfung also der booster
für guten schutz sorgen
wer sich nicht impfen lassen will oder
kann wird sich wohl früher oder später
mit dem saas kopf zwei infizieren die
krankheit cupid 19 verläuft bei jedem
menschen sehr unterschiedlich es gibt
nicht das klassische krankheitsbild und
das macht es schwer ein passendes
medikament zur behandlung zu entwickeln
die in entwicklung oder zugelassenen
medikamente haben also unterschiedliche
funktionen und werden bei
unterschiedlichen symptomen und zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten der
krankheit eingesetzt in der frühen phase
beziehungsweise auch präventiv können
antivirale medikamente zum einsatz
kommen sie sollen verhindern dass die
viren in körperzellen eindringen und
oder sich dort vermehren
so arbeiten wissenschaftler innen
beispielsweise an einem nasenspray dass
die viruslast in den oberen atemwegen
stark reduzieren oder die viren gar
unwirksam machen wird
sehr viel tut sich im bereich der
antikörper medikamente dabei dienen die
antikörper corona kranker das sind
proteine die das immunsystem herstellt
um sich gegen das virus zu schützen als
vorlage und werden im labor sozusagen
nachgebaut diese müssen aber in der
frühen phase der infektion verabreicht
werden
für spätere phasen der krankheit werden
unter anderem besondere herz kreislauf
medikamente entwickelt sie sollen die
blutgefäße das herz und weitere organe
vor komplikationen durch eine coop 19
erkrankungen schützen
das sind nur einige beispiele der über
600 arzneien die sich im test oder
zulassungsverfahren befinden aber eines
ist klar sie alle dienen nur der
bekämpfung der folgen der krankheit
medikamente direkt gegen eine virus
erkrankung zu entwickeln ist sehr
schwierig
die meisten existierenden medikamente
gegen virusinfektionen sind vom mäßig
wirksam beispielsweise gegen die
herpesviren
ungeimpfte erkrankten oft schwerer und
sind deutlich länger ansteckend weil sie
das virus länger in sich tragen der
wirksamste schutz gegen kuwait 19 ist
die impfung nach einschätzungen von
expertinnen hält er nach der dritten
impfung längerfristig
forscher in versuchen sich auch an
möglichen kombi impfstoffen die
gleichzeitig gegen grippe und corona
viren wirksam sein könnten um gegen saas
kauf 2 und mögliche varianten gewappnet
zu sein braucht deutschland eine
impfquote von mindestens 85 prozent